ahora hablemos de algo que probablemente
es la macro molécula más importante de
la vida y se conoce como ácido nucleico
pero de dónde viene ese nombre bueno los
científicos lo observaron primero en el
núcleo de las células de ahí proviene la
parte nucleico y como tiene propiedades
ácidas por eso se llama ácido el ácido
nucleico más famoso es el ácido
desoxirribonucleico adn para abreviar
más adelante profundizaremos en todo
esto al realizar nuestro viaje por la
biología pero tal vez ustedes ya sabían
que esta es la molécula que almacena
nuestra información genética a grandes
rasgos el adn es lo que hace que tú seas
tú y se sabe que es una macromolécula ya
hemos hablado de macromoléculas en otros
vídeos también hemos hablado de
carbohidratos y proteínas el adn es una
macromolécula porque está hecha de
millones de átomos sólo para tener una
idea aquí podemos ver la doble hélice
adn aquí tenemos un lado de la hélice y
aquí tenemos el otro y después tenemos
los escalones o peldaños que forman una
especie de escalera que se va torciendo
ahora en el genoma humano un cromosoma
es una molécula muy larga de adn en
donde su escalera puede tener hasta 100
millones de escalones otra cosa a tomar
en cuenta es que al igual que otras
macromoléculas el adn o mejor dicho los
ácidos nucleicos en general son
polímeros están hechos de bloques de
construcción y esos bloques de
construcción de los ácidos nucleicos
como el adn que ya dijimos que es el
ácido nucleico más famoso o también está
el arn ácido ribonucleico los bloques de
construcción de esas moléculas se
conocen como nucleótidos
nucleótidos aquí tenemos algunos
ejemplos de nucleótidos este es el mono
fosfato de de shocks ya de nothing que
es un nucleótido que se encuentra en el
adn y aquí podemos ver sus diferentes
partes aquí tenemos un grupo fosfato por
acá tenemos un azúcar de 5 carbonos que
en este caso es ribosa y después tenemos
algo conocido como una base nitrogenada
y por qué se llama nitrogenada bueno
porque todas las esferas azules
representan nitrógeno y como ya hemos
visto antes las esferas de color gris
oscuro son los carbonos las de color
rojo son oxígenos y las de color blanco
son hidrógenos entonces esta parte de la
molécula tiene algunas características
básicas mientras que este grupo fosfato
del final tiene algunas características
ácidas lo que ocurre es que son apilados
uno sobre otro y los ribó fosfatos se
alternan para formar el esqueleto de la
molécula de adn
y aquí podemos verlo tenemos un fosfato
y después una ribosa después nuevamente
fosfato y después ribosa y después
tenemos a la base nitrogenada que forma
parte del escalón o peldaño de la
escalera ahora para que el adn pueda
almacenar información
cada una de estas bases nitrogenadas
necesita una base nitrogenada
complementaria para terminar el escalón
por ejemplo en este caso tenemos adenina
y en el adn la adenina se complementa
con la timina y como veremos en futuros
vídeos para la rn la adenina se
complementa con brasil por otro lado la
guanina se complementa con citosina por
ahora no se preocupen mucho por esto
profundizaremos más en otros vídeos
cuando hablemos del adn y de cómo se
almacena la información por ahora solo
es importante saber que el monómero de
un ácido nucleico como el adn es un
nucleótido y para que quede claro este
no es el único monómero
a ti lo análogo en el arn que significa
ácido ribonucleico es el adenosín mono
fosfato y podemos ver la diferencia
entre los dos aquí tenemos un oxígeno
pero aquí no por eso a esta molécula se
le llama de shock sí y por eso este es
el ácido desoxirribonucleico porque le
falta un oxígeno en el carbono 5 del
azúcar ahora como ya dijimos la adenina
no es la única base nitrogenada podemos
tener un nucleótido en donde la base
nitrogenada es timina y estos dos se
parecen mucho pero observen lo que está
pasando aquí también podemos encontrar
un nucleótido que se ve así nuevamente
tenemos el carbono número 5 tenemos el
grupo fosfato pero la base nitrogenada
sigue cambiando y el orden de esos
nucleótidos diferentes es lo que
codifica la información en el adn
una pregunta que tal vez se hagan es oye
si tenemos esta parte de la molécula que
tiene características básicas porque se
considera un ácido bueno observen cómo
está estructurada la molécula las partes
básicas forman los escalones o peldaños
de la escalera así que no serán tan
reactivos porque se encuentran más cerca
del interior de la molécula mientras que
las partes ácidas que son los grupos
fosfato se encuentran en el exterior
serán más reactivos por eso es que la
molécula entera tiene características
ácidas vamos a dejarlo hasta aquí más
adelante en otros vídeos profundizaremos
más en la importancia de los ácidos
nucleicos sobre todo del adn y el arn y
sólo para valorar qué tan fascinante son
estas moléculas algunos científicos
tienen la teoría de que los primeros
signos de vida fueron moléculas de arn
que se auto replicaron y eventualmente
quedaron encerradas en algún tipo de
membranas que en algún momento
sharon a formar la máquina genética de
una célula etcétera etcétera por eso es
que muchas veces los ácidos nucleicos
son considerados como las macromoléculas
fundamentales de la vida nos vemos en
otro vídeo